hey guys this is Pete peppers and so
walk through three level 74 Katie
persisted maybe this is a pretty tough
level and a little bit easier than it
used to be but it's still paying so have
much people asking about it don't try to
go ahead and take care of it
and give you some tips as we go so the
main thing here is that all the Bears
are on top you got six of them and
they're all up there where you can't
really do much so this is really this
board really depends on specials you
talked about and use it on
as you can see we have a color bomb here
but I want to try to use it the combo if
I can if I had a red one right here that
might be pretty good or an orange even
but blue and green isn't gonna help much
maybe the green would free up the fish
blue doesn't do much at all and yellow
doesn't do much at all so I'm just gonna
cycle the pieces and you see that I can
set up
we do want to get this free if we can so
if we go to stripes above it will
definitely make that so now it looks
like we're stuck we're gonna have to use
collarbone I think he got it was
slightly better than that's not very
good
all right so here we can make up the
stripes that we need but we we also need
to fire it off what you're gonna do now
and this is a pretty good scenario
because it's gonna take the licorice off
the color bomb and then we have a
striped candy next to it I want to make
the fish first I don't see what
hopefully it won't you know sometimes
when you do that it can cause problems
but I don't see anything that's gonna
happen there all right so now we'll use
our combo and that'll start to get you
know some space cleared out but we still
have a lot of work to do when we have 23
moves so we want to be careful when you
get a chance to hit the Bears directly
that's usually good you know it's a
small space so you can't do that that
often all right so here we can make a
setup of wrapped in a fish because I'm
hoping that it'll go up here and clear
out some space for us and I wanted to
take that ice out first so that it
wouldn't you know go there that this is
possible that it would go after all
these blockers down here I think it
should go to the ice first live dig all
right so now we have 15 moves we have
half of our bears you can see one here
one here so there though it must be
right there so this is a good setup here
we could I was just checking to make
sure
like if I can make a color bomb here
that would be good but if I move that
one over I don't really know so it's
gonna take a lot of moves so just like
this year hopefully I'll be able to fire
straight up and hit that we just just
having big color bomb here I'm gonna
actually turned into a coloring candy so
this is pretty fantastic I'm gonna match
the green to get these together and make
this combo and it should really clear
things out
all right good that's good result we'll
still have you know two big blockers
though so we're not out of the woods yet
so I want to study the board down here
and see you know what I'm trying to make
is another big combo
and let's see yeah I think one thing
making this stripe of this fish is
pretty good for right this minute
because it'll go crossed here we don't
want it to go right at this square but I
guess it'll be the end of the world if
it did because actually you know what I
think should match this first clear that
out and even again because now I think
there's a higher higher chance that it
will actually hit exactly where we walk
all right so we only have five minutes
left so this is not ideal because we're
gonna need three hits to finish this off
so we got a fish here we can't use fish
here we can't use and we can make a fish
right here and if we do that that's also
gonna bring this one down so we're gonna
start here it actually didn't anything
but if it set it up so we could use it
so here's one and now this one will be
to just go ahead and match it with the
stripe to this we'll finish it off
and that's it it's a I mean it's a
difficult level and you know this is a
pretty early level in the overall scheme
of things so you might not be familiar
with know the best combos to use and
things like that so hopefully this will
help I thought this was really hard when
I first got to it and it's it was always
strange to me that more people asked
about it so I hope that you know like so
hopefully this will help and you'll get
through it soon hang in there and please
like the video if you Faroese phille and
subscribe to our channel to support us
and then you'll be able to find all the
newest videos where we get to if we're
going to put them out so I'll be making
more soon thanks